une production du studio SF
iltre le podcast où on parle d'histoire
sordide avec nos invités bien connu pour
les histoires
cette semaine on parle du temps sur 10
on parle en fait on a le grand plaisir
j'ai le grand plaisir de recevoir encore
moi plus parce qu'on reçoit mon frère
aujourd'hui Pascal et les deux à
comédiens principale de son dernier film
de leur dernier film les chambres rouges
en Juliette Gariépy et le riz Babin deux
formidables jeunes actrices qui est
déchire qui sont absolument incroyables
dans ce film là
puis dans le fond on parle de du film en
tant que tel on parle de la Genèse
l'idée derrière le film Le concept
derrière le film un peu c'est quoi
l'histoire des anecdotes de tournage
des leur expérience en festival tout
tourne autour de ce féminin je pense que
même si vous l'avez pas vu c'est
intéressant je pense que si vous l'avez
vu
c'est encore plus intéressant parce que
certaines scènes on va un petit peu dans
l'analyse du film donc
vous pouvez écouter le podcast vous
pouvez écouter deux fois en fait le
podcast encore mieux
puis c'est un plaisir de recevoir ces
personnes-là les deux filles qui ont que
je connais que moi évidemment je
connaissais moins que mon frère son 2
personnes
qui sont qui sont super qui sont super
et la canne aussi pour parler de du film
de leur personnage
c'est cool on a reçu aussi en même temps
le gars qui a fait de la musique du film
parce que le score original du film puis
honnêtement moi j'ai écouté la veille de
notre enregistrement j'ai écouté le film
comme comme vous allez pouvoir
l'entendre pendant le podcast mais je
vous encourage grandement à aller le
voir puis l'ensemble de l'oeuvre est
grandiose la musique est vraiment forte
à fait vraiment bien avec le film puis
c'est une grandeur j'ai l'impression
pour vrai c'est de quoi de super
marquants c'est une oeuvre vraiment
vraiment marquante qui m'habite encore
ça fait ça les faits maintenant de moins
en moins c'est des films qui m'habitent
longtemps et puis là j'ai l'impression
que j'ai fait là vous m'habiter quand
même longtemps et puis c'est pas peu
dire parce que d'habitude quand tu
connais les artisans du film ça sort un
petit peu du de l'expérience
cinématographique comme on peut dire
mais bla pas du tout allez voir ça
courir au cinéma voir ça au moment où
est-ce que vous écoutez en ce moment ça
va sortir soit dans trois jours ou avant
bientôt très bientôt ou c'est déjà sorti
quand vous avez posé
le 11 août il faut aller voir le film
allez-y en salle c'est ça risque d'être
vraiment débile fait que courir au
cinéma c'est une belle occasion aussi de
renouer avec le cinéma le cinéma
québécois c'est important pour soutenir
cet art c'est vraiment perdition très
cool une très belle conversation avec
les artisans qui ont fabriqué ce film
donc bon podcast bonne écoute
aujourd'hui est présenté par mandycape
m'inscape
des frissons à chaque fois juste nommé
c'est comme un
[Musique]
au gris de sa volonté mais j'avais juste
un moustache un peu trop longue c'est
juste un peu trop longue que 30 dans la
bouche à matin clic-clac juste tailler
ça à la perfection c'est un outil qui
qu'on peut avoir la longueur désirée on
peut aussi juste enlever le bout de
plastique ici puis là vraiment rimé à
avec une précision incroyable
pige est terminé ça avec la petite rue
la barbe la brosse toute le kit ici pour
avoir une barbe incroyable mais Skype
c'est des produits c'est ils ont tout en
fait pour justement moi vous le savez le
ben j'ai pas donné déjà parlé peut-être
que si c'est la première fois que vous
entendez de m'inscrire vous dites c'est
dégueulasse c'est des malades mentaux là
mais j'utilise le body wash et le 2 en 1
pour shampoing revitalisant honnêtement
à toutes mes douches puis c'est mes
produits préférés j'en ai testé beaucoup
parce que moi je suis souvent en clore
parce que je fais de la natation puis le
l'odeur de classe ça reste longtemps si
tu as pas les bons produits le body wash
the man's Skype il sent bon il élimine
toutes les odeurs de classe sur ma peau
puis il y a aussi le petit spray
hydratant leurs produits sont débiles
mental si vous allez voir le je vous
conseille grandement en fait déjà aller
voir sur le site et de vous procurer ça
à vous ou à un être cher utiliser le
code promo sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais et la livraison gratuite c'est un
sacré bondeal et en plus à leurs indique
que vous écoutez le podcast vous voulez
supporter le podcast fait que allez-y
courez sauter là-dessus merci Mans skate
oh yeah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde salut salut
ça se peut que je perd mes mots parce
que j'ai pas dormi de la nuit parce que
j'écoutais le film hier soir
puis elle vient de déménager
mon affaire pour cacher mes yeux je
regardais autour de moi c'est vraiment
le comme nerveux toute la nuit
au festival les gens n'y avaient
vraiment peur mais ouais ok mais c'est
drôle parce que nous on a non c'est
vraiment cool mais mais nous on a peur
de le mettre l'étiquette film d'horreur
au film
d'horreur ça vient quand avec des
attentes c'est comme des codes tu
croises les bras puis un peu fais-moi
peur
il se construit d'une façon quand même
patiente et il s'en va
ouais c'est ça c'est ça exactement je
pense que l'état d'esprit est meilleur
si on on joue pas trop fort sur la note
de film d'horreur mais après on contrôle
pas par exemple que les gens en disent
puis on voit toutes les critiques disent
comme ça
un des meilleurs films d'horreur de tous
les temps
j'ai l'impression que tu vois le faire à
manipuler
hein
je pense que quand même quelqu'un qui
voit pour la première fois parce que moi
quand je l'ai vu au début
mais tu es comme des fois par exemple
dans mettons moi des fois j'ai pris plus
en écoutant genre pop fiction qu'une
comédie des fois c'est comme quand
l'humour est un peu non sollicité mais
arrive au bon moment de la bonne façon
on dirait que je puisse pro à rire puis
je pense que c'est la même logique un
peu pour l'horreur le film de surprend
dans quelque chose de très tourmenté de
trop tourmenté en tout cas bref mais
cool et c'est la première fois aussi que
tu rencontres
juste pour rebondir sur ce moi je suis
la seule personne autour de cette table
là qui a vu le film
a fini après toutes les étapes fait que
j'imagine que mon expérience était pas
la même clavier puis c'est ça je disais
tantôt c'est la première fois que je
vous vois en vrai puis la dernière fois
je vous ai vu c'est hier soir devant mon
écran fait que ça me fait quand même
bizarre
exactement la même personne
[Rires]
vous allez voir son vrai nom différente
de leur personnage
des des réponses puis que ce que les
gens me disaient au festival est-ce
qu'il y avait ceux qui sortait quand les
gens voyaient après avoir vu le film il
y avait-il d'habitude la difficulté à
faire la dissociation entre vous et le
personnage
peut-être moi je pense que mon
personnage est pas carrément un comique
releave mais il est quand même attachant
dans un univers où il y a encore plein
de choses
exactement
[Musique]
dans un univers où c'est difficile de
s'attacher vraiment au personnage de
Kelian parce qu'on on
les gens qui m'approchaient je sentais
qu'ils avaient comme beaucoup d'amour
pour moi parce que ils avaient vraiment
stressé pendant ce film là puis mettons
un truc peut-être qui brûle les couilles
je sais pas trop mais on peut être
discerner en fait
du bulgare
le film va être sorti dans quelque chose
sur pause allez écouter le film de toute
façon
mais si vous voulez vraiment à éviter
tout
spoilera pas dans les punchlap il était
mais on va quand même parler de soi
non mais c'est ça mais juste dans le
fond que les gens qui m'approchaient je
sentais que il m'aimait beaucoup parce
que je leur avais comme permis de
s'attacher
dans un film qui fait super parfait
[Rires]
non c'était vraiment spécial je me
rappelle au début je pense quand la
salle s'ouvre tout on est comme hier là
après quand les lumières se rouvrent
puis tout le monde a fini le film je me
rappelle vraiment des yeux un peu comme
oui
mais je me rappelle aussi de
comme quand les gens venaient me voir
vraiment
sourire j'étais contente mais comme
j'étais je voulais faire un peu exprès
mais je sais que en mettant je voyais
comme deux madame qui sont venus de
parler ils venait de voir le film puis
tes jambes le riz tu es tellement plus
belle en vrai en plus
contente de te voir un bon moment puis
moi je te jure
sur le tournage même l'actrice qui joue
Elisabeth voulait j'en mets presque même
pas me parler ou même pas me voir sur le
coup mais je comprends mais j'imagine
quelque chose qui a marché pourquoi en
fait parce que je pense surtout que les
scènes qu'on faisait sur le moment et
était comme toucher pendant présence
puis
rester là-dedans peut-être à se donner
un coup quand je la vois Juliette ça
parle ça parle émotion que je sois tout
le temps au top que je viens avec elle
il y a personne qui était comme méthode
sur le tournage si je vous entre les
prix tu redevenez Juliette c'était drôle
puis tu es même chose pour le riz
Elizabeth elle se mettait quand même un
peu dans sa beur Elizabeth juste mini
contexte c'est celle qui joue la la mère
d'une des victimes c'est qu'il devient
un peu la porte-parole des victimes
comme toujours craqué le 11 c'est moi
j'ai regardé beaucoup de
vidéos des des meilleurs là bon qui qui
c'est ceux qui prennent l'espace public
pour pour fondre le bon pour trouver
justice en ce que bref elles sont tout
le temps le charger là il y a comme une
colère des roches pas c'est comme un des
boules dogs un peu Elisabeth Vador on le
cassé parce qu'on trouvait qu'à
l'amenait à la elle était juste assez
bouledogue mais on a trouvé aussi
touchante tu sais on voulait comme que
le personnage que des personnages un peu
se réchauffent face à présence d'une
certaine façon mais pitié on faisait
beaucoup de prises quand même le bouche
pas c'est pour ça
on faisait qu'Elizabeth quand même des
10 12 prises pitié tout le temps des
fois en plus moi c'est drôle c'est si
vous vous rappelez les comme quand on
faisait les répétitions mécaniques parce
que moi j'essaie de créer une logique ou
la première prise peut être la bonne
comme on brûlera pas et puis je rappelle
je vous disais tout le temps dans les
répètes donnez-moi un 6/10 ou un 7 sur
mais elle était comme pas capable de pas
aller là
on fait des répètes mécaniques on en
fait quatre cinq même la première prise
qui est
[Rires]
je peux comprendre qu'il fallait que des
fois à une bulle mon Dieu parce que tout
le temps dans la tête dans le mur
mais mettons juste pour remettre les
nouveaux outils
que on fait un petit résumé c'est moi
qui le fait ou si vous êtes ça peut être
n'importe quoi
on choisit peut-être collectivement de
regarder l'autre bord mettons parce
qu'on sait que ça ça doit exister
finalement les gens rouges
en fait Juliette le bien dit parce que
commençant par là mettons des groupies
c'est vrai que c'est le point de départ
du du truc tu m'avais pour la première
fois parlé de ce projet là qui était
comme que tu avais peut-être en tête
c'était vraiment seul
le point de départ c'était vraiment mais
ça m'intéresse le point de vue de
renverser un point de vue ben non ça
devient beaucoup plus en fait genre
anglais sur comme
comment accéder à un monde secret comme
on naviguait cette violence là qui est
dans les vêtements qui est comme dans
font un monde internet qui est qu'on est
pas sûr qui existe mais on est on pense
que oui ou les gens consomment du
contenu ou en achète alors
que c'est littéralement dans le folklore
on va y venir là parce que le film on
peut pas démoniser nécessairement la
technologie en tant que telle bon bref
c'est un débat mais c'est en fait des
snuff des vidéos de meurtres de torture
qui seraient été diffusé live pour des
gens qui tentent le principe
comme des gens qui font de la webcam
comme les gentils bref l'interactivité
puis là je trouvais ça intéressant parce
que là tout à coup le témoin parce que
l'idée d'avoir par exemple une groupie
ou quelqu'un une femme obsédé par une
sœur bon c'est bien beau mais on veut
toujours que nos protagonistes soient
actifs du récit soit participatif dans
le récit ça prend un certain temps dans
le film avant que les motivations
c'est à dire le film carbure beaucoup
facilement la première heure sur le
mystère qui est-ce qui a fait là c'est
quoi son delael what the fuck
c'est mal étirer très longtemps le cette
perdurer après
ça peut quand même être interpréter de
te rendre manières oui exacte mais elle
devient réellement réellement réellement
participatif mettons dans la deuxième
moitié du film puis c'était viol aspect
cyber criminalité et donc interactivité
entre c'est comme si un pont direct
entre l'acte horrible qui est commis
puis l'audiment l'audience et puis
comment finalement l'un nourrit l'autre
puisque une danse qui joue à deux puis
là c'est d'autant plus glauque aussi tir
je je pense et puis bon on le personnage
de Juliette c'est plein de choses c'est
il y a un petit côté leslander peut-être
mais on s'en est dissocié tu sais c'est
comme si quelqu'un qui était en anglais
l'adjectif Tex avis le test quelqu'un
qui est très très
techno officiel
bon profil
évidemment il y avait la comparaison
avec le personnage de la culture pop qui
est fort qui est le mais dans le
lisbether mais on l'a quasiment
construit plus qu'un genre de
spectrales millénaire on dirait on
dirait qu'est-ce que le film sauf
qu'elle se réveille d'un sommeil de
Milan puis que c'est ensuite elle
redéparaît dans le néant il y a quelque
chose de très comme Batman
voilà comme son serviteur doit-il à sort
juste qu'on a besoin d'aide sinon on
sait pas après à la fin du film on
dirait qu'elle pourrait ne jamais avoir
exister
de vent je reste des jeunes victimes
c'est qu'il y avait comme forme bon bref
tous ces interprétations amusantes
peut-être bon mais mais la société
c'est ça non mais c'est c'est
non non non
comme il y a tout un
monde déjà
associé qui ont des vies en ligne très
très riche ensemble et étrange d'exister
d'être complètement c'est des gens qu'on
voit pas qui prennent le métro qu'on
peut croiser dans la rue bon bref peu
importe mais qui tout à coup sur
Internet
moi ça c'était très intéressant je pense
comme construction personnelle puis
juste pour pour continuer là-dessus
c'est quoi la part des tirs parce que
clairement parce que tu fais des
recherches avant de en écrivant ton
scénario puis sur cette chose là c'est
quoi la part de trucs qu'on sait qui
sont existent pour vraiment ça parce que
je comprends que on parle aux
conditionnels serait un endroit pour
faire ça parce que c'est ça je dis Adom
tantôt tu sais c'est que mettons pour
avoir accès à ça faut justement que tu
sois profitant
technologies beaucoup le dire moi dans
un sujet sieste ça va être incapable de
m'y rendre
après il y a pas tu vas pas sur Google
quand tu arrives là il y a pas un Google
m'acheter un battle c'est pas simple
comme ça
95% des pages de Spa de ce cas de ton ta
carte de crédit tu penses que tu achètes
un bazooka mais finalement tu fais juste
à quitter ton affaire ouais bon il y a
beaucoup de ça aussi
déjà écoute il y a parenthèse sur Thor
moi je je pourrais même dire que je suis
trop tard dans la mesure où mettre donc
on fait une analogie imaginons que c'est
une cape d'invisibilité pour les femmes
d'Harry Potter là la cape d'invisibilité
est-ce qu'elle est il va dans soi je ne
pense pas je pense que c'est pour aller
dans le vestiaire des filles
[Rires]
parce que tu vas le montant marche pas
on est dans une par exemple une guerre
en Ukraine qui finit pas de finir et qui
est empêtré c'est comment tu penses tu
sais c'est sûr qu'ils font de la
surveillance de communication tu es la
seule et unique façon de de cette
organiser des fois que dans les pays
répressifs qui ont des oppresseurs des
gens qui te surveillent ça sonne
peut-être un peu parano dit même là je
le spottant bref mais la technologie
n'est pas évaluation ceci étant aussi
l'idée par exemple que il peut savoir
des vidéos de meurtre live c'est pas non
plus réservé au darkway dans le sens où
tu pourrais faire un groupe sur discord
avec des gens que tu tu t'assois
DAE je faisais des vidéos de de tes
capitations sur facebook avant que
l'algorithme le flag ben la vidéo elle a
été diffusée et puis il y a plein de
monde qui ont commenté qui ont dit genre
quelqu'un infidèle vient de se faire
décapiter bon c'est un terrain de vie
simple mais je c'est quand même
intéressant le rapport à l'image puis
moi je me rappelle en 2013 c'est la
vidéo de maniotta mettons moi je voulais
pas regarder mettez il y avait tellement
de monde qui l'ont regardé je pense
qu'on connaît tous déjà qui ont regardé
la fameuse vidéo j'ai vu des
statistiques de de combien de vues que
cette vidéo là a eu puis c'est toutes
les centaines de milliers de vues quand
même pour regarder un être humain mourir
l'air devant une caméra c'est ça fait
pas de casse
-toi c'est dérangeant puis je pense que
le film via cette espèce de thriller là
il y a une conversation je pense à avoir
sur la consommation l'hygiène de
consommation d'audiovisuel puis les
pulsions qu'on peut avoir vis-à-vis de
ça et puis le phénomène des gens obsédé
par les soirs ou les mais juste grâce à
part des choses très humain intime
mettons quelques personnes se battent
dans la rue où il y a un accident tu
tournes la tête tu regardes tu as envie
de vous foirer de fouiner autour bon
bref on se rappelle la bagarre la seule
bagarre de rue qu'on a vécu une fois
ensemble ou est-ce que rapidement il y a
beaucoup de monde qui sont arrivés
autour de nous quand
ça manque de citron
c'était vous la bagarre
[Rires]
extrêmement court extrêmement court ça
fait longtemps on est on était jeune moi
j'étais
chaud extrêmement con je connais
quelqu'un la personne qui cherche c'est
son frère
mais je m'en suis smiley
[Rires]
les jaunes que tu avais sur laquelle tu
avais travaillé pour produire avec un
œil au beurre noir comme une semaine
plus tard c'est comme la
première fois la famille
mais pourquoi pas le dessin
animé
exactement
absolument pitié juste les films pendant
la pandémie pour de vrai le boom du
choucrime il y a jamais été autant fort
moi je suis tombé un peu dans cette
le premier consommateur de toutes les
48000 séries Netflix sur tête Bondy qui
existe mais je finis comme à regarder
plus que qu'habituellement puis tu te
sens toujours un peu drainé à la fin de
ce bas c'est full vampirique je veux
dire ces gens-là c'est des gens souvent
les tueurs en série c'est vraiment
narcissique il y a un geste extrêmement
d'une violence terrible mais qui qui
viennent nautique est vraiment vraiment
narcissique puis le TOC homme une vache
à lait là pour Netflix et autres
des films mais d'autres séries et bref
puis nous on consomme ça on aime ça
genre il y a quand même quelque chose de
conversation à avoir mais moi je trouve
c'est drôle parce que je consomme plus
de contenu aussi puis c'est drôle parce
que eux ils commencent l'histoire on
sait pas jusqu'à la finalité puis
contrairement à la finale on s'en fout
un peu on sait qu'il meurt à la fin
c'est vraiment la quête qui nous
intéresse dans le podcast ou dans le
contenu qu'on écoute sauf que nous ça
commence avec la fatalité des limaces
ont déjà faites la quête fait juste se
rétrécir se préciser c'est tout au
contraire on va pas dans le charisme du
tueur parce que ce qui est déjà fait il
doit régler on sait c'est qui là on va
dans toute le reste mais j'avoue que oui
c'est comme du tout mais on fonctionne
pas avec la même stimuli de plaisir de
build up de gens juste plus plus plus
puis à la fin les victimes puis la mort
ça se trouve ça fait l'inverse de
l'effet des des trucs oui nous c'est ça
ouais
[Musique]
parce que vous comme c'est sur papier
les rôles je pense puis je vais pas
parler de vous mais ça paraît que il y a
de la matière graphique il y a un défi
de comédiens aller chercher puis on peut
s'amuser avec la matériel mais quand tu
lisais le scénario le tueur ici c'est
presque rien dit là bon d'autant plus
hein
mémoriser les lines non mais déjà
exactement
[Rires]
c'est pour attirer des comédiens
intéressantes pour vouloir qui vont
vouloir le jouer enfin je t'ai déjà dit
moi de ce rôle là du rôle du soir parce
que j'étais comme ça
puis Maxwell c'est vraiment cool ce qui
me dit d'entrée de jeu
il est vraiment plus comme un défi
d'acteur parce qu'il y a dit si genre je
tousse les gens capotent
les doigts le monde font hâte exactement
donc
fascinante parce que tu dis c'est
vraiment un humain qui a fait ça avec
chaque petit geste humain qui
transparaît glace le sang
merci
chaque chose que que nous on peut faire
se frotter les mains par exemple ça te
rappelle qu'il y ait pas juste un
monstre qui est comme un monstre mais
qui vit dans Ça c'est vrai qui existe en
trois dimensions tout à fait qui est là
puis il l'a vu comme il dit
essentiellement c'est comme clarté sous
microscope puis
puis voilà ouais il l'a vu comme un défi
de comédien puis je suis vraiment
content qu'il l'avait vu comme ça parce
qu'il amène étrangement vraiment quelque
chose
mais vous c'est sûr que sur papier les
rôles c'était des vraies questions que
quand tu as fait le casting parce que
qu'est-ce que tu as appelé je l'ai fait
la bonne question
bah merci merci incroyable si j'étais un
steak mais super bon bah merci tu sais
il y avait déjà Juliette et le riz vous
êtes des très bonnes comédiennes ça
c'est une chose mais puis je dis ça
prenez l'acte des pincettes vous êtes
pas non plus dans toutes les films never
depuis 10 ans
puis moi je ça m'intéresse c'est pas
genre pour coloniser votre talent
non non non non mais c'est vraiment un
choix
sont fiers de découvrir tel comédien
tout ça c'est un peu bizarre
on en parlons plus mais
je suis quand même conscient que d'avoir
des gens qui sont pas nécessairement
ultra méga surexposés à l'écran créer un
rapport entre l'acteur le personnage qui
est des fois un peu plus direct puis
surtout que toi je pense pas non plus
que ça pour revenir à aller se battre sa
Linder je pense que c'est un rasoir que
mettons Rooney Mara dans le temps
c'était quasiment la première fois qu'on
la voyait quand elle veut jouer ce rôle
là il y a quelque chose que rapidement
de déguiser je pense de part et d'autre
dans vous de la brosse mettons j'ai rien
contre le premier donc désolé c'est
l'écoute mais c'est trop dur et long je
pense de se de revenir vierge un peu par
rapport à ce qui nous est proposé alors
que c'est Juliette il y a plein de gens
je pense qu'ils vont te découvrir via ce
film là puis mais ils vont donc prendre
l'énigme du personnage je pense à moi le
corps complètement entièrement puis le
film carbu rassure aussi bon ça c'est en
marge du talent évident je pense que que
vous amenez au film
moi l'idée de effectivement ouais de
même la mer des victimes si je voulais
pas non plus je sais pas encore l'idée
c'est fictif mais c'est peut-être un peu
de s'amuser avec l'idée d'un True Crime
si vous voulez acheter comme si on veut
ces gens-là on les accepte pleinement
puis qu'on sache pas ils viennent de où
mais voici le monde qu'on dépeint et
puis voilà enfin bref il faut donc les
trouver c'est comme médecin comédienne
là puis moi c'est des bons vieux casting
là le riz a une belle histoire de son
audition là
une belle histoire
que j'ai passé de ma vie
Kevin je pense que c'est pour ça qu'on
c'est une audition par zoom j'en ai fait
[Rires]
mais c'est j'ai fait quand même pas mal
d'options en personne puis là c'était un
moment spécifique où il y avait une
reprise covid puis tu sais puis on
allait comme pas encore trouvé
Clémentine puis que fait-il faut qu'on
continue le processus puis j'aime
vraiment pas ça c'est nous Juliette on
s'était vu en personne j'en ai vu plein
en personne puis le risque est une des
rares qu'on a vu par zoom là on était
comme forcés de bon bref ça faisait pas
une affaire moi non plus on a pas fait
largement des auditions par zoom j'y
crois moyen et puis son histoire me
confirme
il construisait dans le fond
un bain dans mon sous-sol ben il
construit
une mec va en fait
c'est un immeuble qui était qui était
mes propriétaires c'était il était dans
la communauté juive puis construisait
une mec va dans mon sous-sol c'est comme
un bain qui est comme super profond
parce que ça doit être utilisé l'eau
genre de la table et en tout cas reste
ça ça nécessitait énormément de
marteau-piqueur cette histoire
est-ce que je fais l'audition dehors
mais là tu es comme j'allais devoir
trouver un wifi pour elle
c'est déjà si vous êtes bonne les
comédiens
pour que cette journée-là ils sont pas
trop intense sur le marteau-piqueur mais
finalement le chocolat que c'est bon
quand même silence j'ouvre ma caméra
puis le manteau
ça rendait je sais pas trop pourquoi
mais ça rendait mon wifi aussi super
fragile fait que des fois je sais pas
mais aussi ça a coupé un petit peu c'est
comme tac tac tac
parce que tu es c'est pas décalé
un live
et puis je pense que c'est toi qui me
faisait la réplique ouais ouais
tu as toujours un petit délai avec les
gens attendais ça replay là je disais ma
replay
je vous jure je suis capable de jouer
mais ayez de l'imagination
l'équivalent d'un callback déguisé un
peu le cas de le permettait justement le
j'ai j'ai une petite atelier puis
Juliette et Laurie ont comme joué
ensemble c'est
Laurent le devant des étudiants puis je
me suis complètement j'ai feeling que le
riz ça bonne personne mais j'avoue que
je suis passé juste des marteaux
je pense que zoom des fois il bloque du
son dans désiré
de à quel point c'était peut-être
l'enfer chez elle aussi
bientôt et donc ta voix
non plus je pense que en tout cas on va
élucider cette fameuse audition ensemble
mais ce sont les ordures ensemble puis
c'était pour tester aussi la chimie tu
sais moi à ce jour tous mes trois longs
c'est beaucoup des duos de personnages
principaux tu sais faire tout un affaire
de chimie il faut que ça marche ensemble
pour que la réaction soit bonne entre
les deux bref et puis sur je trouvais
que vous étiez déjà
une demande de participer à un atelier
de direction du film là on a fait genre
que jamais de la vie j'aurais ce rôle là
que je me suis dit Oh Pascal se sent mal
mais qui m'a
invités
de consommation et on est on reste en
bon terme c'est pas grave tu étais nul
en audition mais viens faire un atelier
avec moi c'est bon j'ai vraiment on
faisait des slime avec Juliette puis
après ça c'est là que moi je savais moi
je pense m'avait dit je t'avais dit
qu'on pressentait très très très
sérieusement le rire moi j'étais dans le
métro avec Glory puis je te jure c'était
fun hein l'atelier
tu peux lui dire ou appelle-nous
vous êtes dans le métro en ce moment
vous êtes les deux
j'ai appelé Dominique la productrice
domino salut j'ai appelé Dominique j'ai
droit je pense c'est Laurie là je pense
c'est c'est fait ça ça silure de dire
puis on se demandait ce qu'on dit tout
de suite ça pourrait être drôle et puis
justement ça fait une histoire à
raconter ça fait un moment c'est comique
c'est cool qu'on était ensemble
c'était aussi le faire un film c'est
beaucoup de quand même moi ma job il y a
une grosse partie de team building quand
même c'est mon bon travail moi
la direction d'acteur je trouve ça très
autoritaire comme ça est-ce qu'on peut
en parler un peu de comment on travaille
ensemble peut-être mais tu sais je vous
dirige tant que ça pas de temps mais
je sais pas
si franchement non mais je sais que
juste un environnement le fun dans
lequel vous vous êtes beau vous êtes à
l'aise et puis vous allez comme donner
maximum tu nous laisses énormément les
mains j'ai trouvé ça vraiment le fun de
travailler avec toi pour ça parce que
justement j'ai l'impression que tu nous
en ligne puis si il y a une direction
qu'on prend qui était pas trop tu nous
le dis on n'est pas ensemble d'accord
parce que genre toutes les chattes qu'on
faisait sont hyper calculées hyper placé
puis ça on a besoin de ça marche c'est
bien qu'on a fait ça comme ça c'est
exactement dans la même direction que
tout ce qu'on a créé depuis le début
fait que ça faisait aussi que finalement
c'est que on nous garde nous les acteurs
dans l'imaginaire la mémoire pas dans le
concret du 7 puis de ton xp la focale
puis OK après tu sors du code bleu
arrive là puis ton ballon mais là on
devait faire ça mais c'était genre
franchement je pense qu'on était quand
même capable de
rester comme dans la magie puis genre
les protections
[Musique]
on peut un peu plus vous bourrez le
crâne de trucs techniques et vraiment
rien contre les filles mettez les filles
c'est les filles
il y a quand même l'idée de c'est une
formation quand même
admettons la seule différence je pense
pas que je diriger plus ou moins mais je
pouvais effectivement on pouvait être un
petit peu plus technique ça se ressent
peut-être dans Comment la caméra autour
de vous avec ça que j'allais dire juste
au début la scène initiale dans dans
l'audience quand ça le procès dans le
procès comme ça comment je veux dire ça
il y a des longs plans séquences ou sur
la caméra se promène puis où est-ce que
les acteurs jouent puis ça c'est quand
même technique ça
c'est comment combien de fois met-on
sans couper ça c'est quoi le plus long
plan
peut-être
c'est quand même quasiment 12 minutes 12
minutes le plus long plan le plus long
que j'ai fait dans les faux tatouages tu
es dans la cantine c'était 8 minutes que
taxi
puis regarder comment
ça en fait
c'est trop inflex quand ça devient un
concours de kicks le plus loin que son
plan tu sais je veux dire mais combien
de temps que vous avez fait alors c'est
selon ça c'est le plan séquence donc
c'est ils font les exposés d'ouverture
de la c'est l'avocate de la procureur
puis ensuite même l'avocat de la défense
il arrive plus belle voix du Québec
en plus c'est drôle parce que parenthèse
le mec si on voulait un petit peu de
théâtraliser les salles de d'audience
parce que les autres c'est leur job les
avocats dans les films ont souvent je
trouve que les c'est très haute puis bon
bref alors je dois être Nathalie Thanos
la comédienne qui fait la procureur
quelque chose de très grande on a décidé
de caster pierre je l'adore je regrette
pas du tout mon choix je pense mais on
le savait qu'il allait amené une
dimension un peu euh
plaidoyer mais surtout
aller jouer avec les sentiments du jury
c'est exactement ça ben c'est sûr be
comme la défense de notre personnage et
mince je voulais quelqu'un qui fasse
effectivement un peu beau parleur puis
que tu dis bah oui même si non pas
encore un peu mais tu as envie de le
croire un peu peut-être ou à tout le
monde une jury que des degrés
d'éducation d'hiver de backgroundiver
peuvent être peut-être effectivement un
peu embourbé dans cette précédente dans
le chaud impressionné par le show boucan
bon bref mais il y a nez quand même
dimension théâtrale un peu puis j'ai
fait là c'est le seul qu'on a pas
auditionné pierre certains acteurs de de
avec un certain statut pierre et Guito
verte qui lui qui joue le jeu c'est les
deux seuls comédiens qu'on a castré
parce que je connaissais leur travail et
puis ça mais j'ai quand même été stressé
ici parce que comme quand on a fait les
premières répètes j'étais quand même ok
peut-être que c'est trop théâtrale ça
marche vraiment pas puis genre ah j'ai
vraiment stressé mais finalement
[Musique]
on a une chance de journée de répétition
là sans les figurants puis tu es avec
seulement les comédiens plus principaux
je pensais pas que tu étais là vous
étiez même pas là les deux filles c'est
ça c'est on a fait avec Nathalie et
dans la presse dans la prise qui a
marché il y a quand même genre Juliette
comme une larme à la fin ouais c'est ça
c'est le directeur photo qu'on s'allume
mais tu vincentage
ça a marché mais justement il y a quand
même quelque chose de magique c'est
vraiment serré avec les princesses
comme pas ça c'est vraiment c'est à dire
la magie du cinéma parlant de l'arme ça
c'est deux les deux maman magique c'est
des moments de larmes il y a l'autre
maman on fait un plan macro là sur
l'oeil de la pupille de Juliette puis on
fait un plan de réflexion de
l'ordinateur dans la pupille de Juliette
puis là on le fait quelquefois ça marche
bien tout seul
mais on continue à rouler pour je me
rappelle plus quelle raison je pense que
quelqu'un a peut-être eu un problème
refaisons une dernière fois puis toi tu
as connu l’œil ouvert très longtemps
naturellement pour humidifier comme ça
pleurer on capote parce que là il y
avait comme une double réflexion parce
que là il y a comme la lame dans l'oeil
qui réf l'écran de l'ordinateur dans la
pupille
oh my god on refait la prise avec la
lave la langue à colle au bon moment ça
c'est magnifique quand ça arrive c'est
peut-être le passé d'athlète mais si
j'essaie de créer des des moments qui
ont actions qui coupaient malgré le côté
calculer de la patente il puisse avoir
c'est ça le petit moment magique qui
s'invente comme pas et puis
la tête que tu as choisi de Maxwell
une coupe d'affaires
[Musique]
au complet c'est tellement difficile à
regarder c'est tellement
deuxième jour premier jour de tournage
on a commencé
le studio on commençait avec ça parce
que c'était c'était un gros préparation
en amont puis ensuite une fois que la
machine à part mais pas que les trois on
a tout fait les salles d'audience en
trois jours on se rappelle c'est des
grosses journées mais c'est quand même
comme quelques minutes écran 3 jours
en Casio tu sais puis ouais c'est ça on
faisait comme les plans de grue
télescopiques les plans de Juliette qui
est gros crazy les plans de thé tout ça
comme un mini film dans le film qu'on a
fait
une grosse couche de stress qui est
descendue pour vrai que le reste du film
c'est quand même
normal
procès André ailleurs
il y avait d'autres défis le tournant en
ville on se rappellera autour du palais
de justice avec tous les défis urbains
que ça représente mais ouais puis
tourner de nuit aussi on a fait par
exemple par la fin du on a refait un
autre gros gros bloc dans le condo là
où Kelian qui vient de notre personnage
[Musique]
mais le donc l'appartement de Kelian
puis là c'était deux nuits c'était comme
une bulle
on était comme un peu fatigué irritable
moment
c'est de rester très très harmonieux
comme tournage je pense mais c'était
plutôt fin de nuit à la fin là
de personnages dans les films que tu
fais puis vaut deux personnages du moins
de mon point de vue à moi il y a
vraiment un genre de ces deux lignes qui
croisent à emmener dans la sympathique
nous on a pour les personnages le dessus
au début personnel de clémentine on
l'aime pas beaucoup là qu'est-ce qui
c'est quoi la fascination plutôt
personnage mais il nous laisse personne
qui viennent nous laisse un peu ni chaud
ni froid parce qu'on a aucune crise mais
quand il y a comme le switch qui se fait
quasiment au milieu du film où est-ce
que la scène où est-ce que vous êtes les
deux devant l'écran d'ordinateur à faire
tu veux qu'on les regarde on les
regardait puis à partir de cette scène
là il y a quand même le switch du Sud je
trouve c'est cool cette trajectoire là
de comme ok là on comprend Clémentine
c'est quand même que tu avais vraiment
pas toutes les infos au titre c'est
juste que elle était perdu
comme beaucoup de personnes doivent être
qui qui fascine sur des tueurs en série
ces choses-là fait que l'on comprend
mieux mais après c'est vraiment chouette
l'autre bar où est-ce que tu fais ok non
cette espèce de
pour deux raisons complètement
différents
au même moment que nous on se le dit
aussi où est-ce que où est-ce que là on
fait le même chemin que que Clémentine
dans le film en disant ok non dans le
fond
vraiment voulu en fait c'est bien de
l'avoir nommé aussi bien non non mais
dans le sens où tu as compris c'est le
film il avait la clé il y a beaucoup de
films qui fonctionnent par principe
d'identification
à un personnage puis tu es donc
relativement facile d'être empathique
d'embarquer dans une proposition
artistique ou d'un des fois des
anti-héros c'est très clair tu les
détestes puis bon c'est ceux qui drivent
la patente ce film là c'est un peu ni un
ni l'autre pendant longtemps c'est ça on
est plus dans fasciné on sait pas trop
des questions ouais mais Clémentine un
certain moment elle devient la bouée de
sauvetage tu le dis un peu
sa réaction vis-à-vis des trucs
horrifiants disons ça comme ça si on
veut rester vague pro vague elle double
je pense la réaction d'une grande
majorité de spectateurs c'est pas tout à
fait normal d'être un peu de turnéon par
des trucs aussi atroces sinon ça comme
ça donc là Clémentine devient cette
espèce de personnage là puis ensuite le
récit il nous prive de clémentine
pendant longtemps puis là on est rendu
dans des territoires très très sombres
et dérangeant
c'est une drôle de trajectoire
qu'on se dit oh mon Dieu on a envie
d'être avec elle mais ensuite c'est non
puis le film nous amène ailleurs c'est
ça
la bouée de sauvetage retourne à tête
Fullman
c'est là que là on a plus de deuxième
perspective dans le fond là on est juste
avec la perspective de Kelian puis là
c'est on suit cette personne
qu'est-ce qui fait que quelqu'un comme
ça tu mettons qui versus une personne
moyenne qui veut juste dire comme
celui-là versus que là de vouloir
prendre part à ce truc là et témoin puis
essayer de tout faire pour sauver ces
personnes
pendant mon background que je me suis
donné l'histoire de clémentine tu es une
réplique où elle dit c'est ses yeux
mentent pas genre de tristesse derrière
les yeux pour moi ça c'est que elle a un
sentiment de d'empathie extrême et
limite genre d'appartenance puis bah
c'est drôle le message je pense je
parlais de ça avec Julie puis on parlait
de Maxwell puis je trouvais mais
peut-être oui mais je trouvais qu'on
avait des yeux un peu similaire
le bleu genre des gros yeux quand même
puis moi ce matin ça me servait comme
casting parce que je trouvais que je
pouvais peut-être me reconnaître dans
ses yeux là regardez puis je pense que
clémentine est et crois à son innocence
parce que elle se dit
c'est comme mes yeux puis moi je
présente je pense aussi que souvent
quand on doute genre de l'innocence ou
de la culpabilité d'une personne c'est
parce que ça c'est comme le personnage
de Pierre Chaniol le dit au début
êtes-vous capable de dire à 100 % hors
de tous deux que c'est lui qui le commit
je pense que juste ça c'était
horizonteux de se dire cette personne-là
pourrait être innocente qui être
condamné et à tort je pense que juste
aussi ça ça rentre un petit peu dans la
motivation Clémentine à être comme
imagine juste imagine qui est innocent
qui est en ce moment tout le Québec est
en train de se mettre contre cette
personne là je pense que elle prend un
petit peu le rôle de sa défendrait
super bien dit le riz mais il y a toute
l'idée
faut pas y mettre une étiquette mais tu
sais c'est
[Musique]
comme dans son introduction elle est là
puis elle parle de la vidéo on l'a pas
vu après truquée il y a des façons
truquées des vidéos et puis ce qui est
quand même dit une position
puis il faut pas non plus juste
sauter dans le ben wagen puis accuser
les gens disaient comme Moyen-Âge bon
bref ça ça va ça va ça va mais plus loin
dans cette salle-là parle de comme la
l'unissage on sait pas si la luissage a
été sédj tout ça tu sais que des gens
qui qui peuvent pas croire cela mais là
tout à coup c'était comme ça puis là on
était juste un poil trop loin que là
c'est vraiment dur de ramener l'humanité
de clémentine tu vas juste un peu trop
loin on juge vite dans les gens et donc
les personnages dans un film
on était comme aller un poil trop loin
et puis ensuite
puis c'est compliqué couper les bottes
final du film il y a moins de
résolutions qu'on a comme fait une coupe
ou on zoomine sur l'axe puis vu que la
caméra assez résolution c'est comme toi
écoute pour ceux qui sauraient vraiment
le film en tête tu sais c'est c'est toi
ton personnage Juliette descend les
escaliers mais ça mettons c'était la
continuité du plan séquence mais c'est
juste genre on a zoomé une sur la
regarde jump côté plus tard dans la
scène en ce moment qui comme recréer une
coupe qui est pas dérangeante peut-être
finalement c'était un plat fréquence
on a truqué notre plan séquence comme on
pouvait faut être ça c'est le problème
de tourner et il y a des bons et des
moins bons côtés de tout c'est très
kamikaze de tourner sans quand je dis
coverage du cinéma classique si je veux
dire tu aurais par exemple un chat un
contre-champ t'aurais des fois des
implants dans le sable tu es un petit
peu ouais c'est ça puis là tu veux
couper une réplique c'est facile si tu
coupes au visage de l'autre puis euh bon
voilà mais si on n'a jamais fait une
visage de l'autre qu'est-ce qu'on fait
si on veut juste couper un petit tronçon
j'avais fait un cours de un
court-métrage au cégep et puis il avait
appris de faire des
si vous voulez encore plus que juste à
couper sur une tasse de café pour passer
à autre chose si vous voulez montrer que
il y a comme le temps qui passe puis ça
crée une impression de pression puis
d'être pressé coupé sur une horloge
j'avais deux personnes qui marchaient
les courants
ils se rencontrent le plus vite possible
c'est comme un peu pressé là on avait
tellement coupé souvent
sur le chiffre 6 avec l'horloge des
secondes
[Rires]
[Musique]
à la
rondeur
dans les cloches cégepi
non d'accord pas fait ça mais
c'est donc c'est kamikaze dans le sens
où encore une fois c'est peut-être
l'athlète qui entre bip et la touche au
mur il y a pas de deuxième principe il
faut que ça soit bon moi c'est c'est en
action coupée il y a comme toute marge
avec en plein milieu ben on reprend à
cause du truc qui marche pas plus mieux
bon bref c'est c'est excitant je pense
de tourner comme ça ça rend ça moins
comme pour les comédiens aussi je pense
que c'est existant pour vous aussi il y
a un vrai défi comme il faut filer la
scène de ce que j'ai trouvé la plus
difficile
la première réplique qui était dit dans
la scène tu es juste satisfait un petit
peu mais tu sais que tu aurais pu la
faire mieux on dirait qu'après ça te
sentais jusqu'à la fin de ta scène dans
5 minutes
[Musique]
on devrait chaque réplique est tellement
importante parce que tu dis que
quand tu tournes avec beaucoup de avec
genre champ contre
là il faut que je répartisse mon énergie
sur toute la scène mais en même temps
vous avez moins de contrôle sur votre
performance dans un cinéma c'est le
moteur puis le Real en salle de montage
dans bien des cas qui fasse
faut vraiment que les gens soient
sensibles
si si votre rythme réel est bon mais
qu'ensuite comme c'est mal monté des
fois les acteurs vous êtes pas meilleurs
vous êtes pas être pire dans un film mal
monté en fait il y a du mais bon
peut-être là-dedans mais c'est ce que je
me rappelle du stress parce que sinon la
scène des cafétéria on avait tellement
d'en faire affaire comme prendre la
salade de pâtes
mais c'était quand même compliqué
de chorégraphie pour pour moi je fais ça
vraiment
un petit mouvement qui avait buggé où
j'avais comme pas pris la salade de
pâtes au bon moment là on dirait que je
rentrais dans ma tête j'avais de la
misère à revenir dans le moment présent
parce que j'étais quand même je veux pas
vu que c'est c'est une scène qui était
quand même assez longue je me disais on
perd tellement de temps si de toute
façon impossible que ça mais si je
faisais confiance que tu allais couper
si tu étais pas sexuel mais ça reste que
j'étais comme ça mettons que je regarde
parce que moi je deviens un spectateur
je dis action mais ensuite j'ai un
moniteur puis j'essaie de regarder un
film que de la robotique puis moi c'est
un petit irritant je me dis ok peut-être
pas puis on dirait que trois strike you
un peu le si je colle coupé en plein
milieu parce que au moins trois affaires
que je commence à la porte était pas ma
maman
était-ce que des fois il y a un petit
héritage tu peux avoir un petit irritant
sur une niaiserie qui met ensuite la
scène elle se déploie d'une très très
belle façon puis ensuite au montage des
comme à l'eau c'est pas grave que le
rythme ici soit un petit peu moins bon
parce que après bref même si si c'est
trois fois que je suis moi en tant que
spectateur je suis comme eux on coupe et
on repart du début le type pour sauver
du temps finalement
on a c'est c'est le film à date où je
faisais le plus de prix je sais pas
pourquoi mais tu on faisait souvent une
10 12 prises quand même on a besoin que
ça soit parfait même si le film avait
besoin d'une précision là évidemment
j'ai vu tout est fait des court-métrage
udiants
mais
c'était loin ton film le plus lécher
c'est toi c'est vraiment
c'est juste shooté puis avoir justement
été un peu de profitation un peu de
liberté de liberté d'imprévus celui-là
probablement qu'il y en a encore mais il
y en a dans un code vraiment plus réussi
mais dans puis je
trouve ça pas vraiment en fait que il y
a vraiment un souci esthétique un souci
du détail rien qui rien qui est hasard
aucun plan qui a été dans le premier
parce qu'on est on est le film le regard
du film la subjectivité du personnage de
Kelian keliane au début du film c'est un
peu un ordinateur ambulant afin que tu
sais je veux dire c'est pas le temps
l'autre filmer à l'épaule puis d'être un
peu là j'adore ça peut marcher à 100%
c'était esthétique là mais là on est
dans la tête d'un moi je l'ai vu comme
ça un peu le film plusieurs phases mais
c'est un peu là on est dans la tête d'un
robot qui glitch
Yamani avec Clémentine dans le récit
comme si un peu Pinocchio qui veut
devenir un humain mais qui sait pas
comment fait que là comme un peu
reptilienne puis elle essaie de comme
calquer genre l'humanité
Clémentine mais c'est encore bon bref
puis ensuite ça paranoïs ça vire ensuite
la dernière phase et on est foulard dans
le fantasme tu le film est très
expressionniste on est la réalité
devient complètement floue bon
quoi c'est ça on il y avait comme pas
jamais de moments pour que improviser
ou alors quand il y a des moments de
liberté c'est genre
moi je ne pense pas que je suis pas du
tout rigide sur le dialogue tel qu'il
est écrit tu sais je pense que vous on
appelle ça c'est de la Bible je pense
c'est comme c'est à dire on suit la
progression du dialogue et pour
improviser du tout le le choix même la
tournure de phrase tant qu'elle dit la
même affaire
ça je pense que des fois vous le disiez
vraiment comme c'est écrit deux fois
papa
vraiment du du film on dirait la pop out
il y a comme des
interactions sont wild genre
non non on joue
c'est c'est vraiment deux personnes qui
qui essaient d'interagir ensemble sont
pas du tout capables
de juste tomber dans comme la miqualité
puis Clémentine c'est un non-starte
a fait quelque chose elle a pas envie de
faire et comme habillé comme mini moi
aussi
il y a quelque chose dans un gros cube
blanc trop éclairé aussi le squash ça
donne ça un peu champ lexical visuels
c'est le squash le condo le soir dans sa
cage littéralement bon bref même l'écran
comme comme
une dimension aussi lecture dit bon bref
mais oui c'est vrai la scène de squash
c'est Pierre à la fête du bien cette
scène là je pense que pourquoi on l'aime
c'est peut-être pas tout le monde qu'il
aime mais est-ce que nous on dit c'est
que ça paraît qu'il y a quand même tout
à coup on peut un peu moins rigide un
peu plus loin même si c'est malaisant
ton non-verbal et le riz
sent tellement ton inconfort c'est c'est
très naturel
mais ce que je voulais dire tantôt c'est
que c'est Juliette il y a eu ben le riz
aussi mais Juliette particulièrement je
peux être il y a eu une grosse
préparation pour ton rôle c'est juste tu
jouais pas squash avant de d'embarquer
dans ce film là
une préparation physique il y a eu
toutes les le monde le merveilleux monde
de la crypto par exemple dire non mais
apprendre sur certaines affaires le
poker
les coupes de marché l'analyse toutes
les le côté hacking un peu même là
énormément mais même une préparation
physique pour le rôle ça c'est cool puis
il joue encore au squash à ce jour tout
seul
mais genre c'est fou parce que j'en
parlais puis le squash c'est un des
activités qui m'ont le plus rapproché en
préparation de mon personnage parce que
[Musique]
ça ça m'intéressait mais c'était
beaucoup dans en fait le dépassement de
soi que je pense à me nourrir genre
parce que faut pas que tout à l'heure
quand elle laisse tomber liane est un
peu partout
je présume je veux pas te mettre de mon
embauche mais il fallait comme avoir un
niveau type il fallait que tu arrives à
un certain niveau quand même ça apparaît
dans la scène quand tu m'expliques
ça paraissait que tu avais faut le
pratiquement obligé d'être pro mais
jusqu'à
quelque chose exactement
[Musique]
l'impression que ça m'a aidé d'être en
mouvement dans le squash une grosse
partie de la préparation c'était
d'arrêter de bouger je demande d'arrêter
d'être parce que je suis très jeune
expressif puis de tout canaliser mon
énergie dans mon regard parce que c'est
tout là que ça se passe
en parler dès le début genre parce
qu'elle était comme Juliette peut-être
tu vas devoir arrêter de bouger comme ça
fini
mon côté explosif et tout il a vu quand
même que je serais capable d'aller là
puis je te jure que oui oui je suis
capable puis c'est de être dans un état
un peu méditatif genre de comme le
regard justement de tout jouer là-dedans
mais c'était vraiment le fun
l'immobilité
on va commencer par parler c'est comme
l'immobilité c'est ton meilleur ami que
je marchais juste dans la rue normale je
trouvais une manière différente de
marcher puis en fait ce que j'ai réalisé
c'est à chaque fois que je bouge ou que
je touche mes cheveux que c'est un
escape c'est c'est comme un c'est plus
facile c'est déroutant puis genre moi je
peux me concentrer sur autre chose que
ce qui se passe vraiment en ce moment
maintenant mais elle à s'enfuit de rien
et pas là-dedans et juste là je trouvais
ça vraiment spécial difficile mais ça
m'a dit de faire de la méditation pas
vrai
la dernière scène où est-ce que Kenya
regarde
la vidéo dans le fond et puis
le contrat est tellement dans les micro
détails j'étais là puis comme c'était
tellement proche que
c'est un sourire
qu'est-ce que genre
à cause des micro millimètres de coin de
bouche qui se relève
ça amène un genre de là on a vraiment
parlé la force du blindface quand est-ce
le faire parce que le spectateur est
projette constamment son imaginaire dans
des visages puis si tu donnes pas tout
ça s'enflamme je pense que le film
carburant énormément à ceux à enflammer
l'imagination du spectateur via Kellian
via comment que le récits narrativement
scénaristiquement construit c'est un
thriller de même avec un tueur on dirait
qu'on y a des codes
qui font leur scénario
c'est quoi son dire
[Musique]
comme ça que quelque chose qui serait
genre je pensais que oui mais bref je
suis bien là-dedans puis c'est un super
défi mais justement j'ai trouvé ça
difficile comme elle vient à m'emmener
dans le film une réussite puis le à
vraiment et on voit la déchirure on voit
les émotions qui sortent puis ça c'est
difficile pourtant je pense que c'est
une de mes seins préférée que je suis
plus fier parce que justement toute la
journée
donc on reste vague
quelque chose
non on était vraiment dans la surprise
je pense que je pense que tu es bien
imaginé parce que justement j'arrivais
pas à
trouver difficile d'aller dans la
surprise puis
génial j'ai gagné tu vois parce que et
pas là jamais donc je suis jamais ou
j'existe à travers ça fait que je me
suis littéralement dit pour vivre une
surprise pour vivre un émerveillement
genre je vais revisiter me remémorer
quand j'ai appris que j'ai eu le rôle
vraiment ça que je vis dans le fond aux
gens ça marche je trouve ça marche parce
que I stand bye surtout cette scène là
mais tout le reste et puis dans la
construction tu sais on a eu même eu
encore même dans l'idée un peu
métaphorique de ce personnage principal
là si on a parlé un peu de sorcières et
puis quasiment comme sourcilerie moderne
ou c'est des trucs de cet ordre-là
mais aussi comme dans le sens où souvent
les personnages féminins sont dans un
jeu de plaire ou pas nécessairement aux
autres personnages je me plaire à nous
le merguez le spectateur qui va genre
consommer du contenu de personnages
féminin selon plein de codes préétablis
blanc tu es trop peu là-dedans
elle n'essaye pas de plaire au monde
mais appelez pas au monde ça marche pas
puis même les spectateurs alors non oUI
NON NON puis si ça fait penser aux
sorcières bien sûr mais à toute le reste
de comme admettons une fille qui est sur
twitch ou qu'une fille qui est comme sur
fortnite puis gens qui se super bonne
c'est
de l'intimidation
mais on reprend le pouvoir télé comme
les femmes qui devenaient médecin
ou genre des
hypocrisie
c'est drôle parce que là comme
l'enveloppe corporelle de genre la
mannequin tu as là puis c'est comme si
ça fait pas avec le mental dans le sens
physiquement et faites dans le monde
alors les privilèges qui viennent avec
genre grande lendemain belge
qu'elle utilise ça comme une cape
magique ou comme un outil pour genre get
away
elle utilise vraiment
je suis seul et donc j'ai accès à ça
c'était fou
de l'importance du de l'imaginaire du
spectateur donc dans le film
initialement le début l'espèce de
snowboard me faisait penser beaucoup à
neune
c'est c'est mon préféré de Nicolas
windingraffen de loin je suis plus un
fan de donner que drive ça me faisait
beaucoup penser à ça puis où est-ce que
genre
il m'a pas habité la seconde que l'écran
était fermé ils n'ont pas habiter
longtemps
mais là c'est pas du tout le cas avec
votre film ou est-ce que là j'y pense tu
es à matin je me suis levé que j'étais
encore dans dans encore en train de
comme réfléchir parce que dans il y a
une demon c'est un slow Banks
l'apogée arrive ça devient super gore tu
te fais montrer qu'est-ce que tu dois
voir maintenant dans ce que dans votre
film c'est vraiment tu te le fais jamais
mon mais c'est insidieux le fait suggéré
puis la pire scène c'est celle qui se
passe dans notre tête de comment
qu'est-ce qui sont en train de regarder
tu peux juste t'imaginer
je trouve que le fait est vraiment plus
débile que n'importe quel film que j'ai
goûté on voit rien là
on a eu notre intime d'ailleurs c'est
très simple plus magnifique
même la violence explicite mais arrêtez
de genre
il y a un plan de douche mais il est
très épuisé bref c'est anecdotique mais
mon point c'est que non non il y a
quelque chose de dérange la suggestion
l'image qui est imprimée dans la tête de
quelqu'un qui imagine bah comme un lit
je veux dire c'est pas tous les livres
que tu peux mettre dans les mains de
tout âge j'ai de toute bref pipi ben
merci déjà c'est un bon parce que c'est
très réfléchi j'essaie humblement via
mon art mi-femme de faire des trucs qui
vont pas à chaque seconde te plaire tout
le temps peut-être que des fois le
rythme va être un peu en train de te
demander où est-ce qu'on est pourquoi
cette scène là tu as l'impression que ça
fait sur place tu es pas certain bon
bref mais
c'est juste comme finalement confiance
dans deux heures on va être rendu
quelque part puis non seulement ça mais
après j'ose espérer qu'il va continuer à
travailler qui va comme cette faux filet
en dessous de la en dessous de ta peau
qui va même j'utilise le terme c'est je
pense que c'est un film qui moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il hante les gens tu
sais ça ça vient avec des fois comme
comment à quel point tu fermes ton film
à la fin à quel point tu laisses sur des
questions à quel point tu bref ou que la
fin rejette une nouvelle lumière sur
d'autres éléments plutôt donc le temps
envie de jouer le film un peu dans ta
tête pour refléchir en lumière de ce que
tu sais au final
longue théâtre pour dire que je
réfléchis énormément à ça d'essayer de
pas faire un film jeté après usage
d'essayer de tu es comme mon petit
je vais vous rester dans votre tête
c'est vrai moi il y a plusieurs
questions qui me dit que justement ou du
moins toute la nuit en y pensant puis en
me réveillant tu sais je veux dire il y
a plusieurs affaires qui font comme qui
font que je leur penser à ça souvent
c'est juste justement
cette espèce de mon underground là qui
existent-ils vraiment ça c'est une
fascination c'est fascinant mais comme
ça habite aussi exactement
comme plus dans quelque chose de moins
en sécurité
de changer vos mots de passe
d'ordinateur dans un sens c'est cool
aussi c'est la scène de hacking moi je
suis vraiment fier c'est pas mal une de
mes seins préférés dans ce que c'est
facile à comprendre
c'est je voulais vraiment éviter ça tu
sais que ce soit comme des lignes de
code qui défilent puis du charabia puis
que ah elle a réussi à trouver moi
c'était quand même ça commence par genre
les traces que la personne a mis
tellement en ligne les outils là tu es
avec google tu peux hacker
il y a aussi cette composante là je
pense qui qui est inscrit dans dans
l'air du temps peut-être mettez-moi
juste te dire aussi la réflexion
esthétique du film d'être pudique
c'est-à-dire de parler de choses de rire
puis de générer les images dans la tête
des gens mais ne pas nous sommes montré
de privé
ça m'est venu beaucoup de moi j'ai
écouté des podcasts d'horreur télé
pasteurs qu'on appelle
mais même victorieux mettez juste des
histoires ça revient à la tradition de
qui on est autour d'un feu de camp et on
va se raconter une histoire de peur puis
après ça on va être un peu bizarre on va
se coucher
je pense j'ai été couché
c'est parfait ça serait un bon film
écoutez genre sur un laptop sur ses
genoux dans une tente encastré
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand même ça
serait horrible d'être dans un laptode
dans ta chambre et moi j'ai écouté
tu l'as vu un peu la première fois que
je l'ai presque finale réécoutez au
complet presque final parce que si je
l'avais vu une première projection puis
après ça en travaillant sur la musique
je voyais des des moments je voulais te
dire tu m'avais envoyé un lien tu devant
la fin puis c'était quand j'étais Hawaii
ma blonde puis on était dans dans une
vanne où est-ce qu'on se parquet un peu
des places louches puis on dormait là ce
que tu as pas vraiment le droit d'être
puis là qui fait noir absolu puis que tu
vois rien et puis on pensait que
l'argent de poche puis là on l'écoute
sur le laptop justement dans ces milieux
gens puis je me souviens je pense que
c'était une dix et une nuit aussi que il
y a peut-être comme une énorme tempête
puis j'arrive bougeais pas rester dans
leur chambre pendant la Commune
d'amiable pour partir par terre
assassiner cette nuit c'est comme c'est
vraiment le justement c'est vraiment
contribué à notre à notre paranoïa non
mais cool mais tout ça c'est super bien
mais tu sais moi-même je suis genre de
gars aussi le côté un film d'horreur des
fois là tu te débandes vite quand tu
vois le monstre
je pense là que comme dit que tu vois là
c'est vraiment bon là tu vois c'est un
exemple c'est c'est le principe de jazz
de alien aussi c'est le moins que tu
montes le plus monde c'est horrifiant
d'une certaine façon mais vraiment c'est
genre juste pour l'anecdote je pense que
j'ai entendu justement c'est une
contrainte en fait c'est une contrainte
parce que le requin mécanique marche pas
dans l'eau salée c'est que genre au
début il voulait voir full mais là
finalement il marche pas l'eau salée
fait que
la question du reading du film si tu
général traitant plus et drôle c'est
comme question difficile à répondre
parce que je t'avais demandé parce que
justement il y a un des amis Vincent qui
a joué du piano sur la musique j'étais
comme penses-tu que Loïc et son fils que
12 ans peut voir le film j'étais comme
la bonne question
mais c'est ce qui décrit et comme tordu
mais il y a comme l'âge maintenant il y
a un âge de Gap
[Musique]
genre moi j'ai un moment dans ma vie où
j'ai caché ce pied et parce que
l'histoire véritable qui arrive vite tu
les entends
telle personne et ça a changé vraiment
vision
[Musique]
alors que ce que tu te rends compte que
il peut nous arriver également
je peux en sécurité je me rappelle c'est
fou genre [__] malheureusement notre
film parle des trucs fucking trash genre
le concept de comme
les agressions sexuelles sur des mineurs
puis moi vraiment quand j'étais jeune je
me rappelle d'avoir compris ça d'avoir
compris oh quelqu'un peut m'agresser ça
existe puis je me rappelle d'avoir
comment douter de tout le monde dans ma
vie dans mes cousins mon parrain puis
mon père et moi c'était donner un petit
phrase genre pour me rassurer moi aussi
ma mère tout le monde avait une phrase
que c'était comme si jamais je t'appelle
puis je te parle de petite école mais
j'aurais peut-être dû mes lunettes
ok mais moi je regarde partout et tout
c'est comme j'ai fait
on parle de quoi
même chose
ça a pas l'air de quelque chose non plus
vraiment je pense que je me dis si ça
doit être pour les femmes on doit
enseigner rapidement oui
je pense que tu le sens autour de toi
cette espèce de comme aura de protection
de ta famille qui est comme c'est vrai
puis c'est pas toi qui donne attention
là tu vas te faire moi c'était comme ça
si jamais quelqu'un te dit que tu dois
garder un secret genre des sous-entendus
c'est fou mais toi c'était une phrase de
même pour dire au cas où mais moi
c'était une phrase genre
est-ce que c'est l'amour de cette
personne est réel de mon père était
comme oui j'en sais ton ex
t'inquiète
de l'amour des gens autour de toi
est-ce que mais je pense pas que tu es à
ce jour tout va bien mais en vrai il y a
eu comme un débat lancement c'est ton
père qui disait oui c'est correct
pH et pour de vrai sur tes épaules
c'était le fun mais après quand je suis
descendu tes épaules j'étais un peu
comme un what genre
oui ok bon next puis vu que c'était mon
père ma mère aurait pu faire la même
chose mais j'avais besoin de faire soit
comme un homme gentil qui me dit genre
bref ouais parce qu'on sait pas toujours
non plus il y aurait pu pas voir quelque
chose
manipuler et je lui posais la question
même puis on s'en est foule pas
elle a 6 ans non mais non mais non c'est
parce que manipulateur direct
j'étais en sécurité mais je pense la
réalité les filles ont ce danger plus
vite pieds
qui peut checker on prend notre temps
c'est ça que je dirais moi parce que si
on imprime des images d'entrée du monde
si tu l'as bien dit c'est comme tout tu
as envie d'imprimer les images de même
dans la tête de quelqu'un de 12 ans
puissance
que mettons 14 ans
il y a un gros il y a quand même une
bonne je trouve que c'est des âges où on
mature vite puis l'histoire est inventé
aussi
une anecdote tu sais moi j'étais
terrorisé par bon disons-le là il y a
une scène où on entend des critiques il
y a une vraie performance d'acteurs
ce qui dans le film est des jeunes
filles qui se font torturer mais qui
dans la vie on est en studio de bain
safe tout va bien
puis moi pendant longtemps par exemple
en montage si on mettait juste un petit
carton dans le bas c'était comme cri
horrible mais ça c'est la
procrastination totale moi j'étais quand
même moi je le sais que comme il va
falloir que il y a des jeunes filles qui
viennent en studio qui crie même faire
une performance des fois c'est pleurer
c'est
quelque chose
que les comédiens le des fois
c'est le c'est qu'on fait un remake
believe lui aussi le thé
mais moi mais mettons moi les diriger en
plus on a suivi la question est-ce que
je prends mes tons
Ramadan
est-ce qu'on prend par exemple des gens
qui ont des voix jeunes en guillemets
ouais parce que tu sais ça prend
peut-être une maturité émotionnelle
c'est pour jouer c'est ça on n'a pas
petite fois qu'il monte faire venir une
fille de 14 ans puis c'est bon bref
finalement on est allé comme non on va
prendre des gens qui ont l'âge de nos
jeunes filles torturées donc c'est très
glauque mettez des gens de genre 14 ans
crie mais quand Actions puis couper on
fait une performance qu'ensuite on va
partir du studio avec le sourire
parce qu'on fait quelque chose de très
sombre que ça se répercute ça ira dit
toute le processus créatif en même temps
je dis ça mettez quand j'ai écrit le
film j'ai été dans une passe assez dirt
c'est une genre de dépression pandémique
un peu quand même c'est glauque faire de
la recherche du trafic humain si je me
suis toujours gardé à un degré de
séparation de mon sujet si tu veux pas
que le FBI vienne chez vous
[Musique]
explique-moi
l'industriel du noise c'est des trucs
vraiment que l'autre puis engine je suis
allé un peu là pareil mais quand même
majoritairement c'est très bienveillant
c'est le film il est pas du tout moi je
me plains pensé que le film est vraiment
pas sadique
c'est une Jupiter
[Musique]
final j'ai
j'ai pressenti
ce qui s'en venait mais j'ai pas
pressenti le deuxième volet complète du
personnage
j'ai pressenti québécois la quête puis
l'objectif derrière mettons le
mécanique mais j'ai pas ce que j'ai pas
pressenti pendant toute puisqu'il m'a
laissé le plus troubler c'est l'autre
aspect complet finalement
des fantasmes aussi
l'objectif le but c'est quoi c'est ça
justice on dirait qu'il y a comme de
quoi encore pire que tu sais parce que
je veux dire il y a quand même
un bon montant de Bitcoin qui s'en va
dans dans quelqu’un qui a quelqu'un qui
a traversé
on calcule rapidement un genre de 650
000 dollars
programmés tous les affaires de Bitcoin
en octobre 2022 le marché
va sortir dans un an à peu près comment
ça va
être conne
beaucoup d'argent qui s'en va quand même
dans cette industrie là peu importe pour
dire que c'est genre tu vois la justice
puis si je peux jeter un peu de lumière
type et puis justement les les
clémentines qu'il y a dans parlait qui
sont vraiment à deux côtés
mettons mais dans les recherches des
jambes CD de parler de soi mettons
Clémentine c'est déni total c'est
mettons c'est un côté l'autre qui est
liane moi ce qui m'a aidé écoute
logement un mot un peu fancy sur le truc
mettons on s'est librisse au filet on en
a pas un peu parler de ça c'est les
bristophilie c'est le terme des gens qui
sont
les crimes horribles mais bon puis ce
sont on peut dire que c'est une déviance
bon comme comme d'autres filles mais
mais ça c'est un petit peu aidé à
comprendre qu'il y a mais c'est que
c'est plein de choses qu'elle vienne
aussi une dimension un peu King fantasme
qui rend son personnage d'autant plus
étrange
est-ce qu'elle fait le bien
ultime menti le fait que tout ça
coexiste contribue encore à l'énigme ça
même si elle voit quelque part les
l'énigme n'est encore pas résolu puis
encore une fois ça ça contribue à
ralentir dont je parlais on continue à
ramener avec ces quoi encore son fucking
idée exactement puis bristophilie aussi
c'est juste pour faire une maison Bonnie
d'abonnés
à vie quelque chose enfin j'étais morte
tout ce temps et maintenant je vis
Kelian c'est un peu ça c'est un peu
morte tu sais tout le temps puis mais
quand tu es dans l'adrénaline tu sais
comme c'est dans la salle aux angles
sous ce qu'a fait à la fin ou ce café
quand elle consomme les vidéos bon c'est
c'est là tout à coup c'est une drogue tu
as besoin de quelque chose que de tout
le temps plus fort
tout le temps plus fort
vu un peu trop jeune aussi
rendu je veux du snuff live que
seulement moi peut voir
c'est que je possède c'est étrange mais
c'est quand même l'espèce de
contradiction ultime dans
l'acte puis on dirait son désir là c'est
comme ce cas c'était les deux directions
que son personnage prend la fin semble
être en contradiction complète
j'ai fait que c'est comme c'est ça qui
reste qui est
intéressant ce que la contradiction j'ai
l'impression qu'on l'a vu tout un
certain niveau dans le sens où on veut
une relation saine mais quand c'est trop
sain c'est plat tu vois ce que je veux
dire on la vit tous un certain niveau
mais elle c'est au plafond
la petite madame faudrait qu'elle aille
la paix pour sa fille mais le moins
t'entretien
pour faire avoir un peu de fun mais bon
je vois
c'est ça
quand même de garder
une humanité malgré l'espèce de
disjonction complète c'est du stock il y
a de la musique
c'est ça c'est là aussi original
c'est la première fois que je fais un
film excuse j'avais déjà complètement
que je fais un film avec un musée
originale c'est pas vrai fan de
seulement qu'on travaille ensemble mais
c'est semi-retour dans un court-métrage
tu avais fait de la musique pour un des
trucs moi vous avez fait des musical
aussi
la fleur de l'âge c'est la
derrière une barrière de avec un
patchworld il y a des il y a des pépites
d'or dans la voiture donc tous mes
courts sont toutes
curieux mais c'est la première fois que
puis est entré mais la manne puis
justement on est en plus quand j'ai
écrit j'écoute de la musique spécifique
fait que je m'attache des fois des
chansons que j'ai écouté en boucle quand
j'écrivais enfin que tu mettais pour
Nadia Butterfly j'ai écouté énormément
de de Beach House puis de grupper en
tout cas bon moi pour les pour les geeks
de musique puis dans le film il y a
beaucoup de Beachers puis de Cooper bon
bref faites-le mais là j'écoutais genre
lingua qu'une hauteur des trucs vraiment
intense en tout cas puis
mais je savais que c'était pas une sorte
de la musique source film là on voulait
essayer de donner une unité puis je le
sais on se parle de musique là je suis
comme c'est un peu c'est un peu de noise
ça peut virer un peu métal c'est bas
c'est comme un amalgame de genre qui
était complètement improbable ben c'est
ça qui était le téléphone qui baroque
mais avec des guides électriques qui
font des bruits puis avec
c'était ça le mélange instrumentation
vraiment comme pouvait on pouvait comme
ça on peut avoir des fois il peut avoir
des tirs
spécifiquement je t'avais un peu à
envoyer c'était Mika Lévy la
compositrice qui a fait ton double de
skin par exemple il y avait des trucs de
petits dans les les corps d'un peu
dissonantes là il y avait peut-être un
petit peu de ça puis on avait parlé un
peu de la musique de Lady van Jones un
peu aussi c'est un petit peu de vestige
de ça aussi mais ceux qui plus justement
baroque plus instrumentation classique
on se parlait de thème si je trouve que
beaucoup de musique contemporaine qui
ose comme pas la mélodie ça c'est juste
comme des plages musicales qui repose
quelque chose mais c'est ouais c'est ça
exactement
une bonne demi-heure plus de musique
originale
mais comment tu as fait genre vraiment
un moment d'explosion Jean sonore il y
en a plusieurs mais comme le cri
on en a on en a parlé beaucoup puis
c'est une des jeunes filles qui est
venue faire des voix c'est ouais à la
fin de leur séance de de performance
d'actrice on a fait de faire des cris
musicaux entre guillemets sachant que
c'est ça qu'on voulait mais c'est parce
que ça là écoute on va dire ici il y
avait une musique dont j'étais
extrêmement attaché c'est une pièce de
linguinota
puis
j'avais comme on a édité le film on a
monté le film littéralement c'est
cru puis l'artiste finalement le juste
dit à protège foule
matériel et on 100% le droit de dire non
les artistes mais c'est le
spécifiquement à marcher tempête comme
dans les projections tests puis là il y
a eu un deuil genre qui est le moment
comme le paroxysme genre du film
quasiment on peut pas avoir la tune que
j'ai écrivait scénario que je l'avais
dans tête que j'ai les monter depuis le
tout début tout début
trauma aussi c'est comme c'est comme
c'est comme un peu c'est très WiCi c'est
très sorti c'est comme genre de
industriel
en même temps c'est super comme plus
petit puisse
de position musique baroque avec par
dessus du noise puis
café alors exactement
attaché à cette pièce là dit non plus
cher pas qu'on pourrait genre jamais à
côté ça puis j'ai été tout autant pour
plein d'autres queues musicaux comme
Dominique m'a envoyé les maquettes
c'était comme super bon je donne une
coupe de notes de tweak de si si ça bing
bang c'était fait puis il y a une coupe
de cue spécifique où j'étais attaché à
la musique temporaire qu'il a fallu
remplacer ou là c'était pour te faire
peur le stage
c'est pas encore assez bon
avec les cris
comme le climax
c'est ça faisait longtemps j'avais
j'avais regardé un centre que je
trouvais aussi difficile à regarder
aussi genre tu sais la regarder mais
genre magnétique là tu peux pas puis la
musique qui était pour beaucoup lighting
était pour beaucoup le le bassing du
film y était aussi pour beaucoup mais
c'était tellement comme vraiment top à
juste tu veux continuer à regarder parce
que tu es quand même hypnotisé mais tu
tu préférerais pas être en train de
regarder
mais oui c'était vraiment le cul de
musique qui était le plus oh attends on
va faire ça là on va voir
ouais il connaît c'est 32 ans avec lui
non mais on dirait que tu
redoutais le moment où est-ce qu'on a
finalement attaquer à cette ouais parce
que c'est comme les climatisfilm parce
que la musique est extrêmement attachée
ce qu'on avait puis là c'était comment
votre chat est capable d'à côté ça parce
que on dirait que tu fais un peu
ça va envoyer des affaires même si
c'était comment est-ce que tu as fait ça
mais on se reparle puis là vraiment
c'est comme fini
tu avais tellement une vision claire
de ce que tu voulais petit on a eu quand
même pas de discussions sur OK c'est
quoi l'univers du film québé il y a un
peu il y a comme un genre de sous texte
thématique un peu médiévale
des ordi c'est vraiment techno enfin il
faut qu'il y aille ça fatigue plein
d'éléments de dans des univers vraiment
différents qui fait que si dans la
musique
[Musique]
il était vraiment bien choisi parce que
tu étais vraiment un ultime geek de
musique c'est une playlist moi je
playlist la même mon film j'ai du fun
à féliciter je me gratte décédé encore
de déniché de la musique t'es pas mal
finalement probablement vraiment plus
mais la manne que moi qui me vient
c'était différent
mais mais tout ça pour dire que tu avais
déjà en tête quand même clairement ce
que tu attendais les trucs qui voulaient
justement c'est une disais tu m'étonnes
pour le thème principal du film
tu t'es comme je veux un thème qu'un
enfant de 5 ans qui a pas de chanter
c'est comme le thème c'est c'est c'est
ça pourrait être ça pourrait être
justement le uber notre vue de 3 ans à
limite
quatre ans
au piano il irait quasiment été capable
mais mais justement c'est quelque chose
de cool là-dedans de faire quelque chose
d'intéressant avec quelque chose de
simple la première fois que j'ai écouté
le film au complet avec la musique
dedans
j'avais tellement tout le temps
travailler sur des scènes
vraiment en visionnelle
pitié il y avait des longs bouts du film
que j'ai pas de musique aussi que
j'avais pratiquement oublié puis
beaucoup plus de musique par exemple
dans la deuxième moitié du film que dans
la première moitié
revient on dirait que la musique comme
crème est plus étrange que je pensais
qui était dans le sens que moi j'étais
dedans j'étais comme ok ouais ça ça fait
c'est cool je pense qu'on a un hiver
puis là des fois tu es 20 minutes sans
musique plus qu'à la musique revient
j'étais comme ça
ça fait tellement
comme c'est il y a beaucoup de musique
de films qui s'invisibilité au sein du
récit puis bon mais moi j'aime ça genre
justement étant un mélange moi ça me va
là que tu sais moi quand on reconnait là
ses affaires
et puis ça prend la place c'est mixer
présent
au début c'est ça je vous disais tantôt
quand vous arrivez tir au début moi que
ma sœur je l'écoutais que ma sœur est là
ma façon on était étonné qu'on se
connaît puis que
je lui donne travaillé dans le bureau là
sur des coups de la musique fait que je
me suis dit au début la musique c'est
quand même elle s'entend des petites
notes le les thèmes sont étés
dans ma robe de chambre dans le studio
là elle va manger des pilotes qui a mixé
ses affaires quand tu travailles des
fois dans le studio mais quand la
musique commence à prendre plus de place
parce que toute bile en même temps on a
même pu penser à la musique en fait je
pense que pas penser à la musique quand
il y a un affaire de même c'est ça le
but parce que c'est trop intense c'est
tellement genre ça colle avec ma fille
exactement
beaucoup la musique qui a été faite dans
le petit
localise
tu as pu aller loin avec tes maquettes
c'est parce que aussi il y a des bons
sympas c'est pour les cordes ici et ça
mais à m'amener ça a repris une autre
cause quand les vrais musiciens ont
embarqué les cordes là par exemple c'est
violent violoncelle c'est pas c'est
c'est il y a comme quand c'est devenu
encore plus un peu plus organique il y a
comme le le ferait à part ça juste by
the way c'est le plus beau moment moi je
pense de tout le processus du film
assisté à la musique de ton film qui se
fait un live par des musiciens alors moi
j'adore
en plus je suis un peu en mode travail
parce que j'ai mon opinion et puis je la
dis oui oui non mais genre non non c'est
que du fun
la musique mais le fait me reste
standard comme on dit c'est lécher il
est proposé il pointu fait qu'il fallait
que ça top mais là c'est comme je sais
pas comment t'expliquer mais on dirait
un peu
genre la musique du futur ou je sais pas
quoi il y a quand même quelque chose de
vraiment riche et sophistiqué c'était
très important qu'on aille le chat
je pense que c'est en lien avec la
personnalité du film c'est qu'une fois
quand j'avais tous mes musiques
temporaires qui a la pièce marchait
assez bien mais il était forcément c'est
des artistes de c'est pas mixer pareil
ça fait playlist mais je trouve que
macramé mais quand c'est tout ensemble
c'est vrai que ça a vraiment une idée et
au final au final façon différente
dans le choix d'instrumentation puis
juste le fait que ça passe tout par à
travers moi qui le fait puis qu'il
m'expliquait c'est pas ça crée une unité
puis tu es dans le fond c'est comme tu
dis tout est cue fonctionnait puis ça a
quand même été
la job faciliter le travail mettons
parce que
il était vraiment déjà bon enfin c'était
comme acquis mais qu'est-ce qu'on garde
de ce truc là c'est quoi que tu aimes
là-dedans dans le fond sauf le garder
l'essence de ça mais rattacher ça à
comme l'espèce le palette de couleur
qu'on voulait utiliser pour le film
faceter ça c'est des fois il y en a un
c'était au Québec ce qui est intéressant
c'est les percussions qui on regarde
l'idée des percussions garde l'idée d'un
cue basé sur quelque chose de rythmique
mais on change un peu la rythmique on
change le tempo puis on change c'est
quoi les autres instruments là-dessus
mais c'est ça la trame de fonte tandis
que fait puis aussi les moments si toi
c'était comme clair aussi c'était où tu
voulais de la musique juste ça ça
facilite plutôt que d'avoir comme un
deux heures de film c'est comme bon ok
on a besoin d'avoir qu'est-ce qu'on a où
est-ce qu'on a pas besoin d'avoir fait
que le fait d'avoir justement la musique
et je pense que j'ai comme un peu panier
moi mon premier score
dans le sens que c'est de la musique la
musique est
elle est partie intégrante du film
c'est à dire c'est ça l'essence parce
que tu l'as très bien dit comme s'ils
l'essence de tout ce que j'amène mes
musiques temporaires a été préservées
mais tout à dans une unités
mais est-ce qu'on va pouvoir le
retrouver sur Spotify les chambres voilà
on veut faire un vinyle aussi ça va
là on est du temps des petits trucs ça
arrive à 38 minutes
38 minutes puis enfin que c'est comme
une partie du revenu
le rouge
mais c'est pas tes fesses autour de la
sortie en salle c'est tout à fait
jouable justement le mastering est super
on est en train on était là-dedans on
faisait des derniers basketball de
mastering fait que tout est bon
incroyable
bien aussi excuse puis juste dire je
l'ai gravé
la musique dans le film tiens mais
attends viens en comme un site de
Londres
moi aussi j'ai hâte de l'écouter comme
tout seul ouais
un petit break de ce film là on en a
parlé
maintenant
tu les sens de Kalyan qui est derrière
son ordi puisque justement qui essaie de
hacker certaines affaires c'est très je
mets des fois je me sentais un peu comme
ça
la musique parce que beaucoup de de
manipulation de dire j'ai fait mettons
pour les cordes je leur ai fait faire
plein de fait déjà juste gratte encore
fait du bruit que ton violon puis là
j'ai pris ça petit j'ai à
l'enversion dans faculté c'était très
c'est c'est cool de pouvoir puis en même
temps de
juxtaposer ça avec une instrumentalité
genre la façon plus classique de qui on
fait un piano puisqu'il y a un beau
piano avec des trucs ça se mélange au
centre design aussi Olivier calvaire qui
est aussi fait le centre design de NASA
Butterfly j'adore aussi c'est même la
musique est très présente quand on sait
pas tout à fait tout le temps quand
est-ce que le centre design fini puis
que la musique commence et vice-versa
aussi
bref
cinq minutes juste pour parler je sais
que tu t'en ailles mais euh
rapidement de
votre voyage en Europe puis de la
première qui demande aussi juste c'était
comment cette semaine j'ai vu sur
Instagram qui écrit c'est la plus belle
semaine de ta vie pourquoi c'est la plus
belle la semaine
mais non mais juste parce que c'est
comme la cumulation du travail puis
c'est la plus belle semaine de ma vie
parce que c'est la plus belle expérience
de ma vie dans son sous genre
de jouer dans un film c'est une croquis
dans la ville c'est pour moi c'est jouer
c'est c'est comme la vie mais mieux fait
c'est sûr que d'avoir une reconnaissance
ou aussi emblématique qu'elle revarie
c'est pour moi c'est genre génial puis
je dis que c'est la plus belle parce que
c'était beau c'était le fun on était en
sécurité on t'a traités super bien tu es
bien reçu mais c'est plus comme le genre
de voir le film dans la salle
puis de sentir la tension comme tu la
sens pas tu es concrètement on voyait
pas les gens mais il y avait comme un
atmosphère dans la salle qui était
vraiment palpable
ou un petit rire ou un petit on lente
mais on l'entend on le
changement
la projection d'équipe c'est le fun mais
tu sais on est entre nous
c'est pas pareil le tout à coup il y a
besoin
[Musique]
la productrice tout le monde vraiment
fière de leur travail
dans la regarder je transpire puis c'est
pas agréable regardez mon prochain film
vraiment pas mais à travers vos yeux
puis la situation a été particulièrement
magique là vraiment avaient des belles
choses à dire puis c'est ça qui fait que
ça vaut vraiment
les plus belles dans la vie
non mais moi je m'attendais je l'adore
notre film mais j'étais tellement
surprise quand les gens nous
applaudissent
la vivarie c'était juste du plaisir moi
j'avais comme pas de stress on dirait
parce que c'était pas le monde que je
connaissais pas genre ma vie mais là
demain moi ça me stresse un peu là on
parle de demain qui quand il est sorti
ça va avoir eu lieu mais c'est sur bref
sachez qu'on enregistre la veille de
notre première en ouverture de Fantasia
la date de sortie officielle 11 ou 11 ou
11 ou puis en ce moment ça sort soit
dans 3 jours
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est vite
fait
le 9 alors on est neuf voilà
on pensait faire une version lawrez puis
la mettre sur un point union genre puis
donc
le spectateur externe
c'est le premier film parce que tu fais
que je
en fait pas que je capable que je pense
même pas au fait que c'est toi parce
qu'on se connaît vraiment bien depuis
longtemps que chacun des films que tu
écoutes soit je suis dedans
c'est quelque chose qui se passe mais là
c'est la première fois que maman
j'écoute le film c'est vierge aucune
première écoute au rien moi j'ai
encourage vivement les gens allez voir
qui est performance sont incroyables la
réalisation la troisième année est
incroyable
beaucoup d'être venu bon bon succès à
demain puis pour la suite merci